how to do everything you want somewhere
along the line you were given some
terrible advice you have to choose a
niche you can safely place a device in
the paper shredder underneath your desk
there may come a time in your career
when you need and want to focus on one
thing but until it arrives you can craft
the work you are meant to do around all
your passions and interests sometimes
finding the work we were born to do may
involve refusing to choose a single
career path even if we can't do
everything some of us want to do more
than one thing remember there's no set
formula for what a career should look
like and we're all making it up as we go
along still jumping from one pursuit or
interest to another or juggling several
at a time can be challenging luckily
there's a strategy that can help you
navigate that bumpy path it's called
work shift work shifting is different
from multitasking it's where you
navigate multiple projects and interests
by focusing fully on something for a
while and then deliberately shifting to
focus fully on something else you can do
this according to a time and calendar
method a project based method or simply
an intuitive as you go method some
questions what should you do
answer it probably doesn't matter so
just pick something there's an old story
of a student who approaches a teacher
the problem familiar to many of us I
have so many ideas the student says but
I don't know which one is best it
probably doesn't matter says a teacher
just pick one of them and do it the
point is that remaining and paralysis is
often worse than making any actionable
choice like it or not by refusing to
make a choice you've already made a
choice to do nothing and doing something
or several things even if they turn out
to be the wrong thing or things it's
almost always better than doing nothing
at all even when you feel paralyzed
indecisive you must find the way to take
action and move forward I heard of a
chef who is so specialized she has
narrowed down her field of expertise to
raw vegan cooking specializing in
avocados and chia seeds
some of us are born that way and
sometimes there can be a lot of value in
becoming the world's leading expert on
your choice of random topic if that's
you you've dedicated to learn hard and
fast on one specific way of life good
for you that's great but for everyone
else who's struggling know that there's
another way you don't have to choose a
niche you probably have more than one
interest and that's what makes it
interesting pursuing a multi-faceted
career or more than one career once may
require more effort than pursuing a
single area of focus you may find
however that the reward is well worth
the effort
why not do it all or at least do a few
things well you can build a life around
all your interests and you don't have to
settle for anything less